hier setzt das kommt der nächste bitte
keine fotos machen sie wenn es keine
fotos
ich möchte keine fotos von masken
feldern jahr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie können die haftung dafür wird zu
einem hohen prozentsatz keine normale
impfung seien also abgeschwächte erreger
oder ähnliche summen stand vor anders
aus
wir haben einen mond system und das muss
eben wir trainieren im täglichen
einschnitte um gehälter sollen um
gemeinsam über anwälte weil es nicht
mehr verantworten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir werden im rahmen oder verschwinden
darstellen dass wir den vielen dank es
ist nicht meine schuld meine leute
wissen dass meine arbeit